hey David so it's what uh my Asian
parents don't approve of my boyfriend
why he ugly just kidding any advice on
how to balance between maintaining a
healthy family relationship and living
my own life hey uh I want you to respond
to this why don't they approve of your
boyfriend I need a little more context
they think he's ugly and he's Blue
Collar while I'm white collar that's
[__] up
hey you gotta have a sense of humor like
I just imagine you talking to your
parents
going like hey this is my boyfriend oh
he's so ugly
what oh my God is that why is it so
hungry is it like uh your boyfriend walk
in I thought he was like a monster
I'm pretty sure you're not are you
Korean what was your ethnicity
Vietnamese okay
the [__] is this Joy oh you brought I
did not come from Vietnam okay for you
to marry a Monster okay so many
different people you have so many pretty
people here why the what the f no matter
this guy here he come here how come his
ass on his face
like what did your parents say I never
seen something so ugly I have the
Nightmare and even in my nightmare you
scare my monster in my head away
look
depicted your parents looking at your
boyfriend and just being
[__] so shocked how hideous he is he
can't be that ugly no he okay he's not I
guarantee you he's not right you seem
like a fantastic person your your
parents most likely are worried about
your future right and I know a lot of
like immigrant parents do this
um I don't know what your parents
background is but a lot of my friends
parents who are Vietnamese refugees have
had it [__] tough man like if you
went to my podcast the genius brain
podcast and you listened to my buddy
David Newman's story you will hear some
of the most horrific things that his
parents went through now having to put
that
there you go so having to put that in
perspective right War refugees from
North Vietnam and he's and you know all
the parents in your struggles they just
want you to live a good life and they
see their daughter who's you know white
collar and literally there's no [__]
on Blue Collar jobs but I think for them
in the most rudimentary way possible
they want you to be with a man who can
provide for you in the traditional sense
right where they're looking at money not
so much as like status but can they take
care of the person that I love right
and that's really what it boils down to
you know a lot of the times for us as
like young Asian Americans I think the
hardest thing or the things that I
[__] up on the most is lacking empathy
for where my parents came from and I
always just thought it was them either
being racist or they were being bigots
or they were really close-minded but it
really wasn't that it was simply I want
my kids to live the best life and
sometimes for them they [__] it up right
because
our our image or our version of the
American dream
tends to be different from our parents
right because what is the American dream
for someone like me or maybe for someone
like you
for me it's Choice the American dream is
literally the ability
to create my own path in Destiny when
they see something like that and they
feel like somebody's not good enough for
their child they're actually more
worried about your future though it's
like in the worst way possible at the
end of the day
it is your responsibility to it's not
just your responsibility it's actually
gonna have to be the person that you're
with his his responsibility too to
trying to win your parents over if he
really does love you and that's the hard
part let me ask you something is your is
your is your boyfriend also Vietnamese
is he from the whitlam